(Dan whispers)
- It's ready.
- Perfect, so hi everyone.
Thank you for being over here.
Hopefully you guys had
a great AWS re:Invent.
As you see, I had one.
I'm starting to lose my
voice, so that's how we know
that actually we're having a great time.
Thank you for being here once again.
So, my name is Dan Dobrescu.
I'm working at Red Hat as a
sales specialist on OpenShift,
and I have with me today Math Bruneau,
who's a senior containers
specialist at AWS.
And we also have our special
guest, Jean-Francois Gamache,
who is the CIO of CAE.
We chose the title today,
"From ground to cloud",
because I think it actually
talks about the aviation world.
Lifting off, gaining speed, and
accelerating into the cloud.
Before we get started,
I would like to set up
a little bit the stage
of what we're gonna be
talking today and OpenShift,
Red Hat OpenShift is something
that's very important
in this presentation and JF
is gonna talk a lot about it.
It's the foundation for their innovation
and as you see over here,
this is our platform.
It can run anywhere, physical,
virtual, cloud, or even Edge,
and that allows customers
to have a great streamline
of application development with CICD.
It reduces operational
overhead and it helps customer
to have a consistent
experience everywhere,
wherever they're running.
And we build everything up from the ground
with our Red Hat Enterprise Linux
and Kubernetes is on top of it.
And I like to say that
Kubernetes is on steroids
with everything that we have over here.
So Math, can you please
tell us a little bit more,
we're at AWS re:Invent,
can you please tell us a little bit more
about how we're working together
and the partnership
between AWS and Red Hat?
- Sure, Dan.
So, the partnership with Red Hat and AWS
go back all the way to 2008
when the first version of
RHEL, Red Hat Enterprise Linux
was actually made available
for you to run on EC2 machine.
Over the years, there was many
addition feature services,
we'll see them in a couple slides,
but you know, one of the
very important launch
was the Red Hat OpenShift offering on AWS
or ROSA as we call it.
Basically today you can run
OpenShift directly on-prem
or you know, you can manage
your own OpenShift platform
on EC2 machine, or if you
want a more managed version,
you can use ROSA, which is
directly managed in partnership
with both Red Hat and AWS
as a platform that you run
to really like, minimize
all the operational overload
that you have to maintain to
have a successful platform.
That do comes with a lot of benefits.
For the actual developer itself,
it's a fully managed clusters,
takes a few minutes to build,
deploy your application,
come all with the great OpenShift toolings
that you're familiar with.
It allows a lot of teams to
calibrate on share projects
in the way that you're familiar with
all the OpenShift platforms
that comes with it.
All the experience of
the OpenShift platform.
For any stressors, more specifically,
it does provide a standardized
and very streamlined
operation across on-prem
and all the cloud environments
where you have OpenShift deployed.
Comes with built-in monitoring, logging
and all kind of networking options.
And basically you can easily
choose to upgrade your version
as you see fit in all
your OpenShift, you know,
across all your OpenShift deployment.
For specific leaders, that
brings in consolidated billings,
you do have visibility on
costs across the whole business
and basically the inside of AWS.
You do have consumption,
the consumption is actually based, sorry,
the pricing is actually
based on consumption,
so you can add and remove nodes,
even giving the regular EC2 pricing
as well as the ROSA specific pricing.
It does come with a 99.95% SLA,
basically 24/7 hours monitoring
by both Red Hat and AWS teams.
But on top of this, it
allows you to use the breadth
and depth of all the AWS services
to augment the capability of your cluster.
So, if you wanna store files in S3
in to database offering, one
of the RDS managed database,
for example, you can do
so directly from ROSA.
You can use the IAM role
to attach the workloads
to those services.
So, it really give a lot of flexibility
into having your workloads in the cloud
in a managed platform,
managed OpenShift platform,
but still use all the
benefit of managed services
that AWS does (clears throat).
So, in a nutshell, right, this
is really a joint offering.
So, you have the regular
OpenShift Container Platform
where you and Red Hat are
responsible for most of the thing.
And as you move into the cloud,
you can deploy your own
OpenShift platform on EC2.
You're still responsible for
most of the aspect of it.
But with ROSA there is
really a simplified platform
where management and supports
is a joint effort by Red Hat
and AWS, so that you can,
you know, move to build,
you know, the most important
feature for your business,
not have to worry about
maintaining the platform yourself.
Dan, you wanna talk about
a couple of other offering?
- Definitely, so I think it's great,
the fact that Red Hat and
AWS are working together.
Again, you are able like
to run it on self-managed
or if you want to actually
release the burden
of managing the cluster itself,
you're actually able to run
it into a managed solution
where Red Hat and AWS are working together
to make sure that you have a great uptime
and you have like the
best of the platform,
the Kubernetes platform.
Again, Math spoke a lot
about the integration
with the different AWS offering,
but we also, like what's
great in marketplace,
you can actually get all the
offerings from Red Hat directly
from the marketplace.
So, you're actually able to
procure them, subscribe, deploy,
and manage them through the
console of the marketplace,
which is something that is very good.
We spoke about earlier about ROSA,
but again, there's a lot more,
there's gonna be Red
Hat Enterprise Linux AI,
we're able to run Red Hat
OpenShift virtualization
in the cloud or different offerings
as Red Hat Automation Platform
that can actually control
on-prem and in the cloud.
Earlier this year at the Red Hat Summit,
we actually had CAE as our main presenter
and they actually won the
Red Hat Innovation Award.
And the reason why they won it,
it was for the advancements
that they did with OpenShift
and the Red Hat products.
Some of them was around like
running mission criticals
applications that actually
allow airplanes to take off
every five seconds.
So, by now about hundred
or more airplanes took off
just in the few minutes that we spoke.
The other stuff was around
for them like to innovate
in their simulators.
So what CAE did, they actually
are running Red Hat OpenShift
inside their simulators.
So those big simulators
that everybody like trains
or the pilots are training on them,
they're actually powered by OpenShift.
The geek inside me loves the fact
that it's like low latency,
it's one platform and so on.
But for CIOs and CEOs,
what actually they like, it's
that they're able to have one
platform that they can
evolve on top of it.
Whatever they wanna run, VMs,
containers or AI workloads.
So that allows for them to have a platform
that can evolve over time
and they can actually
provide to the end customer
the resources that are needed.
Also, something that is very important
is the fact that they're
gonna be able to connect them
together or in order to
reduce the operational risk
and the cost associated with that one.
So without further ado, I'll
pass it over to Jean-Francois
to kinda talk about how
he's keeping aviation safe
and how he partnered with AWS and Red Hat.
Thank you.
- Thank you guys.
- No problem.
- First, just to set up
the context a little bit.
See every time you fly,
every time you step on an aircraft
for business or for pleasure,
there's a big chance that
the pilot trained with us.
We are the largest training
service provider worldwide
for civil aviation and
we extend our services
and our applications
to the defense as well.
Basically, we train more than
150,000 pilots every year.
We manage all the applications.
So we work with the OEMs, we
work with all the airlines,
we work with the pilots to
make the aviation world safer.
So we prepare in the training,
the pilots for the moment that matters.
So in case of an incident
or in case of something that
can happen, they are ready
to respond the right way to that incident.
In addition, we are a global company,
so we train worldwide
in more than 85 sites
in different countries.
That increases the
complexity of those workloads
and those operations.
We also control and operate
the entire value chain
from RND to supply
chain, to manufacturing,
to the training centers,
booking, scheduling
with the pilots, with the
operators, with the instructors,
so the entire value chain.
And more importantly,
we are building everything
from almost from the ground up.
Everything.
So, we have a community of 3000 developers
and that's the reason why I'm here today.
I want to congratulate them for the award
and also thank the partnership
that we are having with AWS
and Red Hat in this journey.
I'm just gonna show you a little video
to show you the magnitude
of the operations.
- [Narrator] At CAE,
our purpose is to make the world safer.
From pilots flying us, to the
people we can't wait to see,
to defense forces
safeguarding what we cherish.
We are proud to be the partner of choice
for those operating in the
most complex environments.
In civil aviation and
defense and security,
we are unleashing the power
of technology to equip people
to perform at their best
when the stakes are highest.
Our commitment is unwavering.
Around the globe, we're
everywhere you need us to be.
Providing cutting edge training
and critical operation solutions
that enhance human
performance and efficiency.
(dramatic music)
We build next generation technology
with a shared common purpose,
shaping a better future.
We are committed to
our customer's success,
to our planet's sustainable future
and to our people's aspirations.
It's an ambitious mission,
but we never compromise.
Our focus remains on revolutionizing
how we will deliver safety for all.
Today and tomorrow.
We'll make sure you're ready
for the moments that matter.
(dramatic music)
- As you can see here,
the aviation industry
is working really hard as a whole
in order to make sure
that the transportation,
the aviation transportation
mode is the safest mode.
By far, it is by far.
Everybody contributes
to this accomplishment
but we think that we
play a big role in this.
We contribute a lot in
this accomplishment.
So as you can see, it's safe to fly.
Concerning CAE, we've been innovating
for the last more than 75 years.
So it's more than eight decades
where we catched tech waves,
one after the other.
And also where we transformed the company
across different business
operating models.
We started as a manufacturing company
and now we are in training
services, recurring services
for pilots worldwide.
And now it's time to think
about the next tech wave.
And this is our big concern.
The tech wave that is coming
in is an important one with AI
and we need to be ready
to catch this next wave.
Also, in addition to the
complexity that I've just described
in terms of operations,
in terms of services
and in terms of critical operations
and the big mission that we
have, to make the world safer.
We see that the industry is
growing, is growing fast.
More passengers, but also
the demand in pilot training
is growing in the next few years.
By 2024, we're gonna have
more than 2.4x more pilots
to train, than we train actually today.
This is because some people
will go in retirement
and also the demand is growing.
So it needs scales.
But in addition to that,
we see that the customers
expectations are growing
because of the applications
they are used to every day.
Prediction, customization,
personalization.
So it's everywhere.
So the expectations are high
and also the complexity of the
technology is always growing
for the developers.
In addition to that, we
have more compliance issues.
Regulation is growing,
compliances are growing,
we have pressure to reduce costs
and increase the quality at the same time.
The same as the other industries.
So, the status quo is not an option.
We absolutely need to change
the way we work all the time.
That has been the case
for the last 80 years.
But right now things evolves
faster with data and AI
and the technology evolves faster.
So the status quo doesn't exist anymore.
And we think that we can't
evolve in an incremental way.
We need to disrupt ourself.
If we don't disrupt yourself
and catch the next wave,
other companies will do.
So that's important to
reinvent the way we work
all the time.
And for this we develop
four basic capabilities
inside the business.
One is on the technology side,
so that's why we are here
with AWS and Red Hat.
We build tech capabilities
in order to go faster
and to innovate more
and to increase the tech
intensity that we have
with the developers
and the capacity that they
have to try something,
learn from this and innovate.
On the other side, it's super important
to change the way we work.
So the operational model,
the operating model is very,
very key in this thing.
It's not just about technology,
but it's also about the culture.
We've been a company based
on projects operating model
and the more we evolve,
we implement a product operating model
which bring more innovation
and a new mindset.
Culture, talent, we need to adjust also.
We are working super
hard to upskill our staff
with the new technology.
The technology right now are
evolving very, very fast.
And of course, I think one
of the or the most important
point, the most important
capacity, capability is the data.
Data, AI capability,
maybe foundational model
that we need to build
internally to boost our AI.
Here it's more the same thing.
What we foresee for the next
wave in terms of technology.
So we modernized in the
twenties with AWS, the cloud.
So that was an important
innovation vector.
Going in the cloud allowed us
to remove lots of tech depth.
With 75 years of legacy, of
course you need to work a lot
on the tech depth.
We also consolidate on
one unique platform,
a smarter platform, OpenShift,
that allowed us to deploy
everywhere the same way.
And it connects also the developers
with platform engineering,
with the complexity of the technology.
So we absolutely want to have a layer
that abstract the complexity from the devs
and to make sure that they can focus
only on the domain problems.
The next wave is gonna be
more about AI and data.
And as you can see here, we
leverage already OpenShift AI
to deploy AI everywhere.
On the Edge as well on the sim.
That's the kind of
infrastructure that shows
at super high level.
The kind of infrastructure
that we have at CAE.
So it's very, very global.
We have eight cloud regions
to be closer to our customers.
We leverage OpenShift everywhere,
so we can deploy across the
entire spectrum of targets
the same way.
So that's one of the reason
we selected the Red Hat
because it's not just on the cloud.
We want to have the same
experience on the cloud,
on the data center and also on
the Edge, on the simulators.
And the more and more we
deployed the AI models
everywhere as well.
One thing that you can see here,
the more we go, an important
aspect is to manage
all the assets that we have
across the entire ecosystem.
So this is gonna give us
a capacity to optimize
all the different processes.
We have data from all
the different regions,
from all the different devices.
So we have data that is
coming from everywhere
in the process.
I said previously that
we control and operate
the entire value chain.
So we have data stream
coming from everywhere
and we're gonna leverage this
to optimize the operations
and optimize the cost, the
quality and the efficiency
of what we do.
AI is not, AI and the
platform is not just changing
the way, the experience,
the customer experience,
but it is also changing
and evolving the experience
the developers are having.
We build a product, a
platform engineering product
with a team and that
consolidate and standardizes
the way all the developers
are working at CAE
in the different product teams.
We have multiple product teams
that are cross-functional
in three continents
and we absolutely want them
to have some guardrails
in order to standardize the way they work.
The more...
It's self-service, it's a
self-service application.
It comes with DevOp as well
on which they can discover their APIs,
discover their building blocks,
discover the CICD templates.
And this fast track all the operations.
This is a set of best practices
and pave path that they
can use to go faster.
Right now there's a big shift
in the platform engineering,
and this is powered by AI.
It had a huge evolution last year
with the different
platforms that we are using.
It helps us to not just remove tech depth
in the different
applications that we support,
but also generating code.
Almost 40% of the code that we produce now
in some cases is generated by AI,
but testing improve the PR,
improve the quality of the code
and in top of that it helps us to remove,
to increase the cybersecurity
ability management.
So that's something that
boosts the experience
with the engineering teams.
At the same time, I
think it's a big factor
to increase the tech intensity.
We have a platform, we
have lots of goodness
that is coming from all the
services provided by the clouds
and all the different
other tools that we have,
but we needed a way to facilitate
the access to those tools
and those capabilities for the engineers.
So that's what we do with this platform.
On top of that, as I said,
the AI is the next big thing.
It's our big mandate right now
to boost the customer experience
with more prediction,
more personalization.
Improve the way the
customers interact with CAE.
Not just the customers but the operators
and also the instructors
and all the planners.
So we have multiple
personnels around the platform
and we need to help them
to accomplish their work.
And on the other side, we have
a big initiative right now
to improve and reinvent the
business operating models.
The key business operating processes.
So basically we start from
mapping the processes,
re-engineer all the processes
and see where we have
opportunities to inject AI
at the enterprise level.
As I said, it's a game
changer also for the employees
and this is gonna be implemented
as well in the product.
We discussed at the beginning
of the presentation,
Dan talked about what we're
doing for the simulators,
but we need to also make sure,
bring this device in the
agentic world and the AI world.
That's something that we do.
So we embed AI in the processes,
we embed AI in the customer
experience within the product
and also we empower the employees
and the developers with AI.
We access through the cloud
to more than 2000 standard
commercial models.
Lots of open source.
We want to innovate with open
source as much as we can,
but also we have access
to different models
and we're trying, we
are experimenting a lot.
Just to show you some
example of the kind of return
of an investment that we see
from dealing with this
technology with Red Hat, AWS.
In terms of...
So basically we see
benefits across the board,
but basically we see cost
reduction in the infrastructure.
We see more efficiency for the deployment
in the terms of quality,
in terms of frequency,
in terms of pace, deployment time as well.
Up to 40%, it's more to
up to 40% more efficient
in terms of cost where we
implemented Red Hat OpenShift
for the infrastructure.
But deployment, which
is a measure that counts
even more for me because we can test more,
we can try more with the customers.
We increase the deployment,
we reduce the deployment time by a lot.
The deployment pace,
we are faster as well.
We do more and maybe more important,
the pull requests are more efficient.
So we do more with the devs.
So those are big numbers.
I think if we look at them
today, it's even more,
it's even better today.
But those are the numbers that
we had maybe 2-3 months ago.
We continuously improve.
An important thing that
I want to mention is,
I talked a lot about the culture
and I talked about our
culture and technology.
Our mixing is mixed together
to increase the way we work
and the way we innovate.
And I think it starts from there.
The innovation loop,
accelerating the innovation loop
or the creation loop.
So, we are using the
technology that we've discussed
in order to improve this innovation loop.
So it starts from, having more speed
is not just delivering more features
for the same amount of time.
For us, the speed is
more to try more things
to the full cycle, increase
the speed of the full cycle
with the customers.
Try more things with the
customers, add feedback very fast.
Feed that feedback into
the product decisions.
So that's the kind of
mindset that we have.
And we wanted a platform where
it's safe for the developers
to test and try, paint and to
get data from those testings.
So the way we see the platform
and the way we are using this technology
is a kind of a learning engine
where every time we test something,
it's an opportunity for
us to have data points.
And from there we improve the products.
So here you can see that we
are using all the AI tool
in order to improve the
code, the speed of the code.
OpenShift is helping also
to reduce the friction
that the developers are
having with the platforms.
So it automates a lot of things.
And all the deployment is
facilitate using those CICD
embedded tools within the platform.
We are using the cloud to
deploy in multiple regions
closer to the customers
doing deployment in range
to test something with customers
that are in a certain range
before deploying this at large.
And with the customers
we can scale, very fast.
We can have the reliability that we want
and have the experience that we expect.
So we are leveraging
all the different tools
and all the different platforms
in order to boost that innovation loop.
In the past, that's not the
operating model that we had.
We were working maybe a couple
of years ago in projects
and that doesn't work
right now in the industry
if you want to disrupt.
Another thing that we see.
We have 2,500 developers
across the planet.
And those are evolving,
technology is evolving.
We need to upskill those
people all the time.
So that's an important aspect as well.
We work with AWS and Red Hat
and we are asking the
devs in the community
to get their certifications,
go to the different courses.
So, we push a lot for this
adoption of the technology
and learning.
So we want them to adopt a growth mindset
and to develop their careers.
We empower them with the partners
in order to make sure that
they are on the edge for this.
So we develop also strong communities.
So with the devs is a,
the developers is a big community,
so it's not under the same thing.
But we manage this as
a group, if you want.
And that's a way for us,
the platform is a way for us
to make sure that we
standardize the way they work,
the way they learn.
We implemented the centers
of excellence as well.
And through partnership,
we make sure that they can have
access to the best courses,
learning and opportunities
to increase their knowledge.
(crowd clapping)
So that's a recap of this presentation
and how we are leveraging the platform.
So basically we have
75 years of experience
and the aviation is still
growing and evolving.
But at the same time, as I
said, we have other challenges.
Because the tech is more complex,
the regulations are growing as well
and the customer's expectation
are always increasing.
So we absolutely need to
change the way we work
all the time, we need to
change the technology,
we need to be ready to
adopt new technologies
and new mindsets.
And for this, as a foundation,
we are using a smart infrastructure
and we are leveraging data and AI
and also platform engineering
to increase the tech intensity
the devs can have with those technologies.
And as a result,
we expect that, right now, as
you've seen in the numbers,
we have very good accomplishments
in terms of safety
with the aviation industry.
But in terms of CAE,
our plan is to deliver
an integrated training
ecosystem, end to end.
Based on data, AI insights,
and bring our expertise to the customers
to deliver more outcomes.
Thank you.
(crowd clapping)